[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
und willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport
schauen wir auf die Nachrichten Themen
dieses freitags
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit nach dem
Erdbeben finden Retter immer noch
Überlebende Hilfen für Syrien kommen nur
langsam voran
Angriffswelle auf die Ukraine Russland
beschießt erneut Städte und
Infrastruktur Kiew fürchtet eine
Offensive
und Heimspiel mit WM Gold Biathletin
Denise Herrmann Wick gewinnt den Sprint
in Oberhof
[Musik]
Tag 5 nach den Erdbeben mittlerweile
wurden 22.000 Tote geborgen 19.000
Menschen starben in der Türkei etwa
3.300 in Syrien und die Zahl der Opfer
dürfte noch weiter steigen besonders
kritisch ist die Situation im Norden
Syrien etwa in der Region um Aleppo
Aleppo hat im Bürgerkrieg mit am meisten
gelitten doch die Katastrophe jetzt sei
schlimmer als die Tage des Krieges sagen
Einwohner das
UN-Flüchtlingshilfswerk schätzt dass
mehr als 5 Millionen Menschen in ganz
Syrien durch das Erdbeben obdachlos
geworden sind goldene atai
48 Stunden war er unter Trümmern als die
Helfer ihn fanden schrie der dreijährige
Tarik nach seiner Schwester aber niemand
in seiner Familie hat überlebt sein
linkes Bein hat er verloren
es gibt immer noch das Risiko dass er
auch das andere Bein verliert und wir
haben noch so viele Kinder die immer
noch nicht gefunden nicht geborgen
werden konnten
Nordwest Syrien am Tag 5 nach dem Beten
hier wo mehr als 4 Millionen Syrer leben
die vor dem Assad Regime geflohen sind
warten sie vergeblich auf internationale
Suchtrupps vergeblich auf Rollen Gerät
Generatoren oder Diesel die
Tatenlosigkeit der Welt werde die
Opferzahlen hier weiter in die Höhe
treiben warnen die zivilschütze der
weiße Himmel
die internationale Gemeinschaft
akzeptiert dass sie gelähmt ist sie
akzeptiert das Russland und das
Assad-Regime keine Hilfe von außen für
uns zulassen dabei hätte sie doch all
die Zeit eine Lösung für uns finden
können
immerhin 29 Laster mit Hilfsgütern haben
es heute aus der Türkei ins syrische
oppositionsgebiet geschafft das nicht
mehr Sport ankommt liegt vor allem an
ihm Baschar al Assad syriens Machthaber
heute besuchte der Mann der systematisch
Krankenhäuser während des Krieges
bombardieren ließ die Erdbebenopfer in
Aleppo mit seinem Verbündeten russland
hat er durchgesetzt dass Nordwest Syrien
kaum noch Hilfe von außen bekommt nicht
einmal jetzt
in Damaskus sind in den vergangenen
Tagen Bergungsexperten und Lieferungen
aus mindestens 14 Nationen gelandet zwar
verspricht das Regime einen Teil davon
über die Frontlinie zu schicken doch die
Erfahrungen von Hilfsorganisationen
damit sind bislang schlecht
auch in der Türkei kämpfen die
Rettungskräfte weiter um jedes einzelne
Leben und 8000 Menschen konnten bisher
aus den Trümmern gerettet werden
darunter auch eine 40-jährige Frau
tagelang hatte ein Team aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen Betonschicht um
Betonschicht abgetragen um sie zu bergen
Lena sünderbruch und an seinem Stern
nach mehr als 100 Stunden unter den
Trümmern gelingt es deutschen Rettern
sehr nett zu befreien ihre Schwester ist
erleichtert und dankbar auch die
Einsatzkräfte selbst überwältigt sie
sind Profis und dennoch haben viele von
ihnen so etwas noch nicht erlebt müssen
sie erleichtert die Frau die hat sich
durchgebissen die hat nicht aufgegeben
und
wir sind alle so dankbar dass sie jetzt
in diesem Rettungswagen liegt und da
fehlen meinem die Worte zwischen toten
Angehörigen lag sehr nett in sieben
Metern Tiefe die Helfer hielten über
einen kleinen schachtkontakt zu ihr
versorgten sie über einen Schlauch mit
Flüssigkeit Tag und Nacht haben die
Rettungskräfte um das Leben der Frau
gekämpft und lagen sich jetzt weinen in
den Armen als sie es geschafft haben sie
haben teilweise ihr Leben riskiert weil
sich die Trümmerteile immer wieder
bewegt haben klar ist auch im selben
Haus in dem diese Frau gefunden wurde
liegen schätzungsweise noch mehr als 30
Leichen im ganzen Land sind mittlerweile
mehr als 100.000 Retter im Einsatz doch
in vielen abgelegenen Gebieten lässt
Hilfe noch immer auf sich warten die
Lage der Menschen könnte tatsächlich
noch mal noch mal wirklich ein ein
großes Problem werden weil hier auch die
Aggressivität wirklich sehr steigt auch
die Wut darüber dass noch sehr sehr
wenig von der Regierung der türkischen
Regierung hier an Hilfe angekommen ist
der türkische Präsident Erdogan
verspricht bei einem Besuch in der
Provinz adea Mann heute finanzielle
Hilfe und einen schnellen Wiederaufbau
in der angrenzenden Provinz caraman
Marash Zeugen tiefe Gräben von denen
gewaltigen Bewegungen im Boden hier im
Epizentrum des ersten Bebens auf
Satellitenbildern ist die zerstörte
Infrastruktur zu erkennen beschädigte
Krankenhäuser eingestürzte Getreidesilos
Erdogans Vision all das innerhalb eines
Jahres wieder aufzubauen könnte gerade
nicht unwahrscheinlicher erscheinen
wir gehen weiter nach Iskenderun die
Stadt liegt am Rand des erdbebengebietes
war ein wichtiger Hafen im Grenzgebiet
der Türkei zu Syrien jetzt ist die Stadt
teilweise überflutet von dort berichtet
Anne Brühl
Wasser von oben für den Hafen von esken
darum durch das Erdbeben waren Feuer
ausgebrochen Container mit Gefahrgut in
Brand geraten
Feuerwehren aus der ganzen Region sind
im Einsatz
dabei gibt es den eskender Run noch so
viel mehr zu tun die Stadt liegt in der
Provinz hartei viele Häuser hier sind
angestürzt
meine Mutter ist unter den Trümmern
meine Nichte sie versuchen mit den
Baggern sie rauszuholen aber bis jetzt
waren sie nicht erfolgreich Abfahrt hat
gesagt dass es zu risikoreich ist bis
jetzt konnten sie keinen erreichen
das ist die türkische
Katastrophenschutzbehörde schwer
vorstellbar dass sie immer noch
Überlebende aus diesem Trümmern hier
Bergen wie viele Menschen alleine hier
gestorben sind wie viele noch vermisst
werden keiner weiß das es gibt bei den
Rettungsarbeiten immer noch Menschen die
wir lebendig rausholen aber diese Arbeit
werden wir innerhalb der nächsten Tage
beenden
von den Behörden sind so viele mit denen
wir sprechen enttäuscht so wie
nazirkulinay die auch noch Freunde
vermisst
kam die Hilfe zu spät
die Helfer kam erst nach zwei Tagen am
Abend Lebensmittel sind nicht wichtig
für uns ist wichtig dass unsere
Angehörigen unter den Trümmern gefunden
werden
Teile der Stadt stehen unter Wasser auch
das eine Folge des Bebens auf Sand und
Beton war dieses Viertel hier am Hafen
von esken darum gebaut als die Erde bebt
der stürzte alles in sich zusammen drei
Meter in die Tiefe
die Fotos die sie im Schutt finden sie
erinnern an die Toten von Iskender rum
die Betroffenheit über die Zerstörung
und die zahlreichen Opfer ist groß viele
haben das Bedürfnis zu helfen nur wie
und was hilft am besten Kleider Decken
oder doch Geld Sven Ricken hat Antworten
die Leute Klasse der Stadtteilschule in
Hamburg gerissen möchte helfen am
liebsten Spenden sammeln am liebsten
sofort Rene Grassau vom Arbeiter
samariter-bund kann sagen was zur Zeit
Sinn macht dennoch ist es schwer private
Sachspenden in die Türkei zu bringen
davon wollen sie sich aber nicht
abhalten lassen das wird vor allem auch
mit Geld spenden an z.B United oder den
ASB direkt auch den Prozess unterstützen
können Sachspenden zu organisieren und
auch vielleicht sogar einfach versuchen
irgendwie eine Hilfsgruppe zu
organisieren das ist Menschen gibt die
wirklich da aktiv mit helfen wollen
vielleicht auch Sachen sortieren was
passiert wenn Sachspenden unsortiert in
der Krisenregion verteilt werden zeigen
diese Aufnahmen aus Karaman Mara die ihr
Lehrer bekommen hat die Kleidung liegt
im Schnee wird nass und ist am Ende
unbrauchbar das heißt wenn man spendet
Sachspenden macht dann muss man schon
hier ist schon sortieren und sortiert
dorthin schicken damit die Leute was
davon haben und nicht alles im Müll
landet die Hilfsorganisationen bekommen
derzeit viel Winterkleidung was die
Menschen in der Türkei aber eigentlich
dringend benötigen ist in den Spenden
setzen nicht drin jetzt konkret heute
bräuchten wir Zelte Isomatten
Schlafsäcke und natürlich braucht es
Geld um alles zu transportieren und um
vor Ort die richtige verteilstruktur
aufzubauen deshalb geraten wir momentan
stark davon ab in das Thema Sachspenden
zu gehen sondern tatsächlich
wirklich monetär zu unterstützen an der
Stadtteilschule in Hamburg rissen wollen
sie auf jeden Fall sammeln Geld spenden
aber auch Sachspenden die sie erst mal
einlagern damit es bei ihnen besser
läuft als auf den Bildern die ihr Lehrer
gezeigt hat
die Hilfsbereitschaft ist gewaltig
allein beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe sind schon mehr als
12,5 Millionen Euro eingegangen und
Hilfe wird weiter gebraucht wenn sie
spenden möchten können Sie das tun beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
IBAN
de65-100-400-100-400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alle
Informationen auch unter spenden.zdf.de
oder im zdf-text auf Seite 890 oder sie
scannen den QR-Code
eben erst hat die EU auf ihrem Gipfel
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten weitere
Hilfe zugesagt heute erlebt das Land
massive russische Drohnen und
Raketenangriffe Ziele waren nach
ukrainischen Angaben vor allem Städte
und das Stromnetz im Großteil des Landes
kam es zur Not Abschaltungen landesweit
war Luftalarm Jürgen Kehl berichtet
wir arbeiten bei Alarm auch hier unten
in der U-Bahn wir haben wichtige
Geschäfte das können wir nicht einfach
unterbrechen
an der Frontlinie im Osten führt noch
eine einzige Straße in das heftig
umkämpfte und von den Russen umzingelte
bachmut
noch kommt Nachschub in die weitgehend
zerstörte Stadt in den letzten Tagen
haben die Russen ihre massiven Attacken
offenbar noch einmal verstärkt
das ist eine schwierige Lage für uns
sagt ein Soldat dem französischen
Fernsehen die Russen schließen uns ein
fast ein Jahr Krieg kein Ende in Sicht
Katrin Eigendorf in Kiev wie schätzen
Sie das ein ist es die befürchtete
Großoffensive der Russen
diese Großoffensive das beobachten wir
seit Tagen hat längst begonnen aber sie
hat heute sicherlich noch einmal einen
Höhepunkt erlebt dass derart massiv auch
Städte von den Russen angegriffen werden
das haben wir seit langem nicht mehr so
erlebt wie heute Angriffe auf separese
Angriffe auf die zweitgrößte Stadt hakif
Angriffe selbst hier auf Kiew wir haben
selber hier einen Teil des Tages
Luftalarm gehabt stundenweise auch in
Luftschutzkellern verbringen müssen es
zielt auf die kritische Infrastruktur
des Landes aber es ist ganz sicherlich
auch Teil dieser befürchteten
Großoffensive und was wir erleben vor
allem auch im Osten der Ukraine jetzt
besonders in bachmut das eben die
Prognosen viele westlichen
Militärexperten dass die Ukraine hier
eigentlich diesen Krieg für sich
entscheiden kann nicht aufgehen gerade
in bachmut erleben wir im Moment
westliche Waffen kommen viel zu spät im
Moment steht das Land zumindest
militärisch mit dem Rücken an der Wand
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung live
aus Kiew Katrin Eigendorf war
zurück nach Deutschland der Tarifstreit
bei der Deutschen Post ist festgefahren
auch die dritte Verhandlungsrunde in
Düsseldorf endete heute ohne Ergebnis
damit drohen jetzt längere massive
Streiks nach den Warnstreiks in den
letzten Tagen verdi hat bereits eine
Urabstimmung über einen Arbeitskampf
angekündigt wegen der hohen Inflation
fordert die Gewerkschaft für die rund
160.000 Beschäftigten 15 Prozent mehr
Lohn
übermorgen wird die Wahl in Berlin
wiederholt weil im September 2021 so
viel schief lief müssen zweieinhalb
Millionen Hauptstädter noch mal über das
Abgeordnetenhaus abstimmen derzeit
regiert Rot-Rot-Grün nach dem aktuellen
Politbarometer extra käme die SPD mit
Bürgermeisterin Giffey auf 21% deutlich
hinter der CDU mit
25%. die Grünen erreichten 17%
unverändert bleiben danach die Linke mit
11 die AFD mit 10 und die FDP mit 6%
alle Zahlen aus dem aktuellen
ZDF-Politbarometer extra zur Berlin-Wahl
finden Sie jederzeit in unserer App oder
auf ZDF heute.de
nach Israel dort gab es wieder einen
mutmaßlichen Terrorangriff in Jerusalem
zwei Menschen starben darunter ein Kind
sechs wurden verletzt ein Palästinenser
war mit seinem Wagen an einer
Bushaltestelle in einem Menschenmenge
gerast er wurde von der Polizei
erschossen nach mehreren Anschlägen ist
die Sicherheitslage in Israel und den
Palästinenser Gebieten extrem angespannt
seit Jahren ringt die Europäische Union
um einen gemeinsamen Kurs in der
Migrationspolitik um sichere Grenzen und
eine gerechte Verteilung von Schutz
suchenden auf einem Sondergipfel haben
sich die 27 Staats- und Regierungschefs
jetzt darauf verständigt die Asylpolitik
zu verschärfen kernpunkte sind
abgelehnte Asylbewerber konsequenter
abschieben und die Außengrenzen besser
schützen Isabel Schäfers
seit 2014 hat sich die Länge der EU
Grenzzäune etwa versefacht auf mehr als
2000 Kilometer weiterhin ist nur ein
kleiner Teil der Grenzen betroffen aber
Zäune sind kein Tabu in Europa nun hatte
vor allem Österreich gefordert die EU
sollen diese auch finanzieren
Außengrenze ist schon eine europäische
Aufgabe
das heißt es gibt an und für sich Mittel
dafür die vorgesehen sind diese Mittel
sollen nun genutzt werden um den
Grenzschutz zu verbessern etwa durch
kameraswachtürme elektronische
Überwachung oder Luftüberwachung eins
allerdings soll auch weiterhin nicht von
der EU finanziert werden Grenzzäune ein
Begriff den auch der Bundeskanzler ganz
bewusst vermeidet ein bisschen plakativ
das von ihnen Verwandte Wort ist in
keinem der Texte die wir beschlossen
haben überhaupt aufgetaucht aber
natürlich geht es schon darum dass auch
in einen ganzen
Sicherungsmaßnahmen ergriffen werden
außerdem soll mehr Druck auf die
Herkunftsstaaten ausgeübt werden diese
sollen abgelehnte Asylbewerber
zurücknehmen im Gegenzug will die EU
mehr legaler Einwanderung von
Arbeitskräften zulassen
in Europa kann auch verstehen dass wir
derzeit unsere Entwicklungshilfe und
Visapolitik komplett getrennt von der
Migrationspolitik betrachten heißt wer
nicht kooperiert dem könnten
Finanzmittel und visaerleichterungen
gestrichen werden einige Sprachen hier
von einem Durchbruch aber festhalten
sollte man auch diese neue scheinbare
Harmonie in der Flüchtlingspolitik
schließt die großen Streitthemen einfach
aus so wurde hier nicht mal darüber
gesprochen wie man künftig Flüchtlinge
innerhalb der EU gerechter verteilen
will und so endet dieser EU-Gipfel in
den frühen Morgenstunden wohl eher mit
einem kleinen Schritt als dem großen
Durchbruch
ein schwerer Unfall auf der A2 heute
morgen ein vollbesetzte Reisebus kam in
der Nähe von Magdeburg von der Fahrbahn
ab und überschlug sich 35 Menschen
wurden verletzt sechs von ihnen schwer
darunter auch der 57-jährige Fahrer der
Bus war unterwegs von Warschau nach
Belgien die Unglücksursache ist noch
unklar
und jetzt Sport wenn die Mama zuguckt
muss man sich schon anstrengen sagte
heute die frischgebackene Biathlon
Weltmeisterin Denise Herrmann Wick also
auch der Mama sei Dank Gold bei der
heimwm in Oberhof das war der große
Traum ein knapper Sieg der Favorit in
dem Sprint über die 7,5 km in der Loipe
war sie wieder mal die schnellste und
beim Schießen heute voll konzentriert
und vieler frei das passte
mit den Klängen von der Zug hat keine
Bremse lässt sich Denise hermannweg
feiern genießt ihren goldenen Moment die
Mission Gold beginnt exakt um 14:42 Uhr
und ist schnell erzählt liegen fünf
Treffer stehend ebenfalls dazu die
schnellste auf der Strecke Bestzeit im
Ziel Gold und das ist halt so ein Rennen
mit 0 im Sprint hier ein Schnee zaubern
kann und das war der
heimweltmeisterschaft das ist einfach
das kann mit Worten nicht beschreiben in
Bildern drückt sich die Emotionalität
aus und auch die Freude welch ein
perfekter Tag für die 34-Jährige das
Podest komplettieren zwei Schwedinnen
Hannah öberg gewinnt Silber Bronze geht
an
dagegen haben die Deutschen
bahnradfahrerinnen bei der EM in der
Schweiz die er hoffte Goldmedaille in
der Mannschaftsverfolgung verpasst die
Olympiasiegerinnen Franziska Brause Lisa
klein Nickel Kröger und Laura süße Milch
sicherten sich im kleinen Finale gegen
Frankreich immerhin noch Platz drei
zuvor hatte Maximilian Dörnbach in 1000
Meter Zeitfahren ebenfalls Bronze geholt
[Applaus]
Sonntagabend die football-show der Super
Bowl zwischen den Philadelphia Eagles
und den Kansas City Chiefs mit zwei
Premieren erstmal spielen zwei schwarze
Quarterbacks gegeneinander hinzu kommt
ein brüderliches Familienduell
zwei Tage noch bevor hier in Glendale 2
Brüder zu Rivalen werden und um den
großen Preis streiten Travis und Jason
Kelsey ein historisches Duell aber nicht
das einzige Novum mit jaylin Herz und
Patrick mahomes stehen sich zum ersten
Mal in der Geschichte des superbows 2
schwarzes starting Quarterbacks
gegenüber
Jaden und ich sind uns um die
historische Bedeutung bewusst wir wollen
eine großartige Show liefern und hoffen
dass es bald nicht so außergewöhnliches
mehr ist
der erfahrenere der beiden zum dritten
Mal steht der wertvollste Spieler der
NFL Saison im größten Football Endspiel
der Welt und könnte seinen zweiten Sieg
holen
das wird ein Spektakel am Sonntag 800
Millionen TV Zuschauer gab es letzte Mal
weltweit du wirst auch dabei natürlich
das samstagswetter bringt ganz im
Südwesten Sonne sonst aber viele Wolken
mit etwas sprühregend die Details hat
gleich Christa orbben Christian Sievers
meldet sich um 22 Uhr mit dem heutigen
Journal die komplette 19 Uhr Crew
wünscht Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende und
tschüss bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses kleine tief Robert
hier sorgt morgen für viele Wolken
allerdings nur für vereinzelt etwas
Regen danach setzt sich schon wieder
hoher Druck durch und hält allen Regen
von uns fern außerdem geht es mit den
Temperaturen etwas aufwärts schon heute
Nacht im Norden verbreitet frostfrei im
Süden aber noch mal Knackigkeit mit bis
-10 Grad hier ist es auch oft klar
stellenweise gibt es Nebel an den Küsten
gibt es einen kräftigen Westwind mit
stürmischen Böden dazu kommen eben von
Norden die Wolken aus denen immer mal
wieder Sprühregen oder schneekiesel
herausfällt das ist nicht viel kann aber
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen örtlich
für Glätte sorgen vor allem in den
frühstücken morgen gibt es im Norden und
in der Mitte viele Wolken auch hier kann
immer mal wieder etwas rausfallen vor
allem am Erzgebirge aber mit Mengen um
die zwei Liter pro Quadratmeter ist es
kaum der Regen Rede wert wenn es nicht
gerade in höheren Lagen gefrierender
Regen ist dazu gibt es im Nordosten
einen kräftigen Westwind auch wieder mit
stürmischen Böen ein ganz anderen Tag
Wind schwach und mit viel Sonne gibt es
vom Schwarzwald bis nach Berchtesgaden
die höchsten Temperaturen gibt es aber
trotzdem am Niederrhein mit um 11 Grad
also richtig gehen mild meist gibt es
fünf bis acht nur hier in Ostbayern bis
ein Grad in den nächsten Tagen setzte
Schritt für Schritt mehr die Sonne durch
dann gibt es Nebel aber Regen und Schnee
sind nicht in Sicht tschüss